good morning of the rules
committee for Thursday twenty
eight to survive cold order
please advise an audio
recording of today's proceedings
being made it is also being
televised America sector please
call Cooley here Cunningham
Carillo care flora Grayson
Kamlager-Dove Maienschein
Mathis works over here
Ramos here previous year Wicks
here we have a quorum we have
accordingly consent agenda
today -- who is our motion
on the consent generation
removed former national rumbles
seconded by Mister for --
madam secretary please
call the roll Cooley fine
Cooley aye Cunningham Carillo
Carillo aye flora -- or
aye Grayson aye Grayson aye
Kamlager-Dove Kamlager-Dove
right Maienschein aye
Maienschein aye Mathis aye
Mathis aye quirk Silva aye
quirk Silva aye rooms right
now most aye revenge side
three of us I Wicks with side
mission motions passed in
a thank you whose insurance